chris marquès keita de temps
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors ils ont plein de questions pour
toi ah bon ah ouais parce que tous
travaillent avec moi pour la première
fois et c'est vrai qu'on s'est régalé et
les chéris dia côté de moi m'ont crise
d'abord on va élire le meilleur danseur
ce soir alors il y aura vous êtes puis
tu auras quarts de finale demi finale et
finale
d'abord ils vont s'affronter sur quelle
danse crise déjà on va commencer par une
salle sache quoi alors une salsa
attention les affrontements vont être
puisque c'est un tirage au sort vraiment
c'est une vidéo montre un plaindre il va
nous montrer
il y aura à gâteau proulx l'un des boys
à face perdu ces noms font face à des
[Applaudissements]
non non non vous dansez chacun pour la
première fois de ma vie sera jigar
sézanne gâteau posé sa table on s'arrête
à l'écran et où c'est normal dans une ou
deux croit pas oui ok deuxième quart de
finale il opposera maxime ghani à
benjamin castaldi que c'est fort
attention troisième quart de finale ce
sera
kelly b novelli quand vous connaissez un
petit peu qui sera opposé à jean michel
maire
il est bête et là vous n'êtes pas
ensemble c'est un couteau utilisé mais
jean-luc non c'est pas possible tu as eu
lieu dans celui-ci
enfin bernard montiel
on vérifie normalement il est contre
celles qui restent a annoncé isabelle
morini bosc
mais ce sera un combat senior en gadgets
pour le dernier affrontement regarder la
battle de danse mais regardez comme
c'est bien c'est partout c'est là le
premier affrontement agathe contre
gilles d'abord crise oui avec quoi comme
dans science à la salsa la salsa bien
sûr las la fameuse chouïa salsa du
groupe tunisien mais chérie ça ce
tirreno une petite démonstration n'y a
pas de lumière sur le plateau ici là on
peut pas mettre un peu plus en lumière
non merci merci je comptais de savoir
c'est par des petits pas de salsa salsa
c'est quoi
d'abord appris ça va côté et à
madagascar et tu voyais à la saga
parfois y avait un beau monde donc pas
de côté c'est le patou sens de base
avant arrière et vraiment il faut y
aller avec les hanches parce que ça
c'est ce qu'ils payent recrutement
tapageur contre agathe
[Applaudissements]
toi
il
dans les yeux et qualité dans ce duel
inédit la vérité pour moi ça doit être
agathe mais vous êtes posséder quand
vous pensez qu'ils n'hésitent pas
franchement accès vers comme tulle et
dans danse avec les stars
dis lui qui danse comme une merde il a
progressé minimum quoi bon bah c'est
vrai qu'il a progressé depuis la
dernière fois qu'il a dansé c'est vrai
qu'à progresser vous êtes éliminés au
point de vue le soir mais kito agathe
contredit donc ça gâte ses qualités en
2006 en quarts de finale en demi-finale
des ans et là c'est maxime contre
benjamin sur la salsa toujours c'est
parti
oh la la
quelle bande de ringards
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le meilleur là ça va être compliqué
quelques danses et côtoie la celui qui a
le mieux danser mais pour moi
techniquement de très très loin bien sûr
major a glissé une marche bien c'est
vrai et c'est un maxime c'était
personnel il y avait il y avait de
l'interprétation mais bon techniquement
c'est vrai que vous remarquerez vous
remarquerez que benjamin est venu au
bicross sur la tête de ma mère il a les
chaussures les plus jeunes du monde mais
c'est la possible les plus jeunes on
dirait karcher café les chaussures c'est
le jaune de karcher mais je conçois
vraie celle là ce nouveau meurtre qui
les a vendu mon frère les l'appel trompa
feria sur la tête de ma mère est un mec
à acheter des chaussures car fait un le
mec connu la de la télé la halle mois le
con là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attention troisième affrontement talent
sa ké li vé novelli est ce que vous
savez dire qu'elle iv novelli vous
[Rires]
mettrez moi j'ai livé novelli merci
contre jean michel maire c'est triste je
me présente quoi il a fait des cartes de
vie j'ai mis officiel malheureusement la
drees et des âmes déjà prises
donc j'ai dit qu'elle ait eu bon style
officiellement son talent vient du rhône
de lyon
excusez moi en fait y'a que vous êtes
seul là dans votre mairie vous êtes
seulement aider à avancer bien avant
c'est bien une musique il va un peu plus
vite
oui à choisir non t'es pas chez toi meme
s est pas belle la m audy tu fais ce
qu'on dit tu fais bien oui pardon
chaque fois tu vas me donner plus non
j'ai dit c'est parti qui dit contre
jean-michel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc cette année en fait de boeck tête
première vers des outils vous êtes
dégoûtés
c'est parti on recommence
[Musique]
pas faux très dur alors compliqué très
dur c'est bien la croire que la fisa
jean-michel oui telli o'kelly fabuleuse
et jean michel est allé saluer jean
michel jean michel ce n'est pas la même
danse allez jean michel noir vous adorez
président et kelly patron de bercy et
[Applaudissements]
plus de changer les roues pour tous bio
âgées qui nous regarde s'ils se
rappellent de la chance aux chansons et
l'imposture
c'est un combat le senior mais néanmoins
il bouge encore
je serais surpris bernard montiel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il
ad et vous avez écouté ce qu'il a dit
c'est pas du tout vous avez vous écouté
ce qui vous a dit oui mais d'abord c'est
un miracle rcp qui s'est donc vous avez
raison c'était un merengue
oui mais on a un pouvoir s'asseoir et sa
sensualité vraiment chez moi alors je
suis désolé ouais aussi je pense c'est
isabelle qui danse le japon + 4
on voit toujours les bateaux
[Musique]
alors terminée selon bernard il aurait
fait il aurait fallu à danser à ce
moment là parce que là pour le coup elle
a plus donné il ya le respect de l'âge
aussi je comprends nommé final on va
jouer on va jouer on va jouer avec elle
danse du jive du jazz le jazz
et
vous
[Applaudissements]
le bois sont dits déçus mais pas aux
journées
d'abord
lens je souhaite qu'ils vont être
initiés finale agathe contrebande
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non mais bon c'est là qu'ils vont en
finale
benji benjamin bassamat qui seront au
final est que ces chaussures dégueulasse
[Musique]
d'accord
alors qu'est-ce que naturellement rester
en tête chez albert solitaire isabelle
je n'ai jamais vu un jour mais c'est bon
c'est bon allez il est lourd il ya deux
écoles où vous pensez danse où vous
pensez audimat savez que j'ai des
chiffres qui tombent tous les quarts
d'heure les deux danses très bien un
randonneur mais qu'est-ce qui est un
bras d'honneur
alors d'après vous à plug ou la plainte
du maire alors qui va se retrouver en
finale face à bages à la gacilly et
seulement finale 2 de la finale de danse
touche pas à mon poste
ça vous dit tu peux le niveau alors
alors qu'elisabeth beaucoup d'énergie
beaucoup d'implication isabelle on avait
même du french cancan de temps en temps
c'est sympa c'est du frais du concombre
[Rires]
non mais mais je n'en dise que tu goûtes
isabelle en finale pour moi
je suis maintenant prêt à donner alors
[Applaudissements]
attention la pile sur une danse
freestyle a eu peur quand même triste
times d'accord est-ce que vous êtes
prêts à temps il vient pas là bas et
pour cela il vous regarde d'ici vous
inquiétez pas c'est une danse est une
danse libre
c'est parti mais un top
à sec
[Applaudissements]
gaza 12 heures
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu vas me dire dans l'oreille qui a
gagné je peux la battle de danse on va
voir appeler les pronostics sur twitter
mettez-vous l'un à côté de l'autre comme
dans la nouvelle faisait main dans la
main dans la main comme dans sec et
sabra dans la main pendant du régime
parce qu'elle plus génial quand même si
c'est votre danse ou ses scieries
réellement impressionné franchement là
c'est bon tenez vous la main et
attention à aa
j'espère y en dans le naufrage mais ils
savent n'avait pas les mains moites et
moi toujours dans l'oreille de biens
privés demandent en plus c'est un grand
moment de télévision
la moitié de la musique elle saura vous
des pronostics
1 sur twitter ça vous regarde ses deux
enfants isabelle morini-bosc 1
le spécialiste de la danse chris marquez
cm community manager a eu envie de
s'ouvrir les veines de gagnant
m
[Applaudissements]
alors
il est bon le gagnant est
benjamin castaldi
[Applaudissements]
e